oh wait it's like groundhog day it's
every day
it's aaron rodgers day because the
hijacking of the draft has continued for
now the seventh day
and
a couple of items emerged today shereen
let's start with bob mcginn of the
athletic when he's not talking to enough
scouts to harvest negative information
about draft picks he's getting some good
information about the things aaron
rodgers may or may not be doing and
according to mcginn
rogers has mocked
general manager brian goody-goon stories
far called him on his podcast guten
hurst which i actually like better he
has mocked goody koontz and called him
jerry krause which i would assume in the
general manager industry is the
equivalent of being called something
that can't be repeated in any setting
even satellite or cable so
uh we have that new development as we
learn more about the extent to which
aaron rodgers really doesn't like brian
gutie coast
uh he really really doesn't like brian
gurkuts he doesn't like you mike he
doesn't like his family he doesn't seem
to like anyone
but he really is anyone really
you just made the list
i did and and brett barr has been on the
list and somehow has managed to get his
way off the list and i don't know how he
quite does that but brian guticus is
probably first on that list right now
mike based on
what we what we read and heard today
it really is amazing how this stuff just
keeps cascading it keeps coming out and
i don't know
where the leaks are coming from now
originally i think everything was coming
from rogers or his camp
now
it could be
selective leaks made by
the team made by people with the
organization who aren't happy with this
or just teammates who have had enough of
it but it may not be roger's now and i
don't know that it helps rogers to leak
that he mocks gouda kunst and calls him
jerry krause i don't know that that's a
good look and i don't know that's the
kind of thing that's going to cause
packers fans to feel good about
aaron rodgers and that leads to the
other report today
from mike geroffolo of nfl media
that farv actually warned
prospective free agents packers players
who were due to become free agents aaron
rodgers said that uh
that
he's not going to be there in 2021 so
whether it's david bachtiari who stayed
corey linsley who left aaron jones who
stayed any of the prospective free
agents aaron rodgers was telling them
according to garofolo
that
he's
not going to be there to me shireen that
was stunning
absolutely you're dismantling your team
or trying to it seems like now they got
some of those guys to stay but we know
that money talks and and the packers
gave them a lot of money to get them to
stay there's no question about that but
yeah it's stunning that you would tell
teammates hey i'm not gonna be there
this team basically what you're saying
is this team may be in sort of a rebuild
mode with a young quarterback who's
unproven at this point because i'm the
guy to lead to the super bowl and i may
not be there and i don't plan on being
there so this was stunning mike no
question
yeah and
look
i i i'm trying to be
so objective on this that i'm worried
about things that i probably shouldn't
worry about i mean packers fans can
judge this for themselves i am not
trying to stir the pot here i always
stir the pot generally if stirring the
pot
is the natural byproduct of being honest
about what i see what i see here and i
think i would believe this for any
quarterback under any circumstance
regardless of what he's said about me in
the past regardless of how he feels
about me regardless of how i've
criticized him and i've praised him as a
player just a few weeks ago i was saying
they should hire him on jeopardy that he
would be great and he was great as the
host i'm capable of being objective and
in this specific instance my objective
analysis is if i'm a packers fan i am
upset
with the knowledge that aaron rodgers
was actively undermining the best
interests of the team
telling guys don't bother to resign
basically even though that may have not
have been the exact language look
what you should do at a minimum say
nothing
nothing
right right guys thinking about
re-signing oh you know i may not be here
next year don't say anything don't say
anything don't try to sabotage what the
team's trying to do and holding other
players on the roster same thing that i
felt about
launching this crusade against the
packers on draft deck
distracting the front office distracting
brian
at a time when he should be completely
and totally focused as focused as all
other general managers are on the three
days of the draft trade up trade down
who do i pick what do i do how do we
read our board how do we make these
decisions in a compressed time frame you
don't need that crap hovering over your
head so if i'm a packers fan i'm getting
more and more pissed off at aaron
rodgers sharing
yeah and i heard last night at the
brewers game there was a smattering of
booze when they showed aaron rodgers
even on the school on the video board or
something like that but this is only
going to grow for packers fans
uh you know and i think aaron rodgers
was very concerned about that i think he
wanted his cake and to eat it too he he
wants to leave there's no question about
that i think we can all agree on that i
think packers fans can even see that now
aaron rodgers wants to leave this team
he doesn't want to be back but how does
he do it gracefully and i think it's
past that point at this point mike i
think there's no graceful leaving for
aaron rodgers he turned off packers fans
and more and more keeps coming out every
single day and it's probably going to
continue to come out and it just makes
aaron rodgers look worse and worse and
worse as he plans his exit out of green
bay
and something you pointed out yesterday
when he first
started this after they lost the
buccaneers in the nfc championship and
we all reacted to it when he made the
comments suggesting that his own future
is uncertain
two days later he cleared it all up
before it could become a thing now it
continues to dominate the sport now you
can't act like i didn't know this was a
big deal now if you want to put
wait for it
the toothpaste back in the toothpaste
holder now is the time well it's already
too late it's already too late that's
the thing even if he would try now
and my understanding is he's told at
least one teammate i don't know what the
big deal is well okay
if you don't there's something wrong
with you because
it is a big deal you helped make it a
big deal your camp helped make it a big
deal and there's been nothing to un-make
it a big deal i mean the bottom line is
he talked to mike tarico on saturday
wouldn't go on camera that's fine that's
his prerogative when he went on camera
with twin spires but didn't talk about
the packers but he wouldn't talk
on camera with nbc about the packers but
he said to rico on the record
enough to make to rico believe and
communicate that there's a fissure
there's a chasm between rogers in the
front office and he expressed regret
rogers did her disappointment that it
came out but it's out he didn't say it
doesn't exist he simply expressed regret
that it came out
how big of a deal is this mike well an
mvp has never left the team
the year after he won the mvp award and
gone on to another team we've had two
retire the year after they won the award
but never
an mvp go to a different team so that's
how big this is this is huge and you
could squash this if you wanted if aaron
rodgers wanted this to end now it says
hey i'm happy with the packard go on the
pat mcafee show i'm i'm happy with the
packers i'm coming back i'm going to win
another mvp award try to win the super
bowl blah blah blah he hasn't done that
so we we get where aaron rodgers is by
his silence he tells us where he is and
the fact is he wants out of green bay
that much has become painfully obvious
to packers fans as well
yeah and uh with each passing hour
it's becoming harder and harder for him
to undo this
and i don't know that he wants to at
this point again when you're really
smart you get
the benefit of the doubt that everything
you've done
is calculated and strategic and
uh
if it isn't then he's not as smart as we
all think brett favre
was on radio today with willian tausch
espn radio here's favre talking about a
communication that he had with aaron
rodgers regarding the situation
they were willing to trade me it sounds
like the packers now are not willing to
trade
um
aaron
you know it's a tug of war so it's it's
similar but but also very different than
my situation i just sent aaron a message
and said hey
am i going to see you playing for the
saints this year just kind of joking
and he sent back hey buddy
uh i don't believe that's going to
happen uh
you know and also in that text i just
said hey i hope everything's okay
you know i i'm getting a lot of
messages from people asking me what's
the deal and he said hey thanks for
checking on me uh i'll touch base with
you
after all this is over
after all this is over which implies
there is something there that needs to
be over and will be over eventually it's
not this is no big deal it's not don't
believe what you read at
profootballtalk.com don't waste your
time reading that crap he could have
said anything he wanted in response to
the brett favre text message and the
response was i'll check in with you when
this is all over further confirming that
there's something there and look he's
not going to play for the saints because
the packers aren't going to trade him to
the saints the saints don't need him the
saints can't afford him the packers
don't want him in the conference
that doesn't mean he's not going to be
traded and
that's a separate issue altogether but
clearly
as far as further confirmed by talking
directly to rogers there's something
there
there is something there mike in and
it's irreparable at this point and it
started back we all know with the jordan
love selection
and i don't think they did a good job of
communicating with aaron rodgers about
what they intended to do that they were
going to trade up that they were going
to draft a quarterback and they passed
on a talented group of receivers by
doing that now if you look at their
draft this year they've helped their
team they had a really good draft by all
accounts but aaron rodgers may not be
there this year to take advantage of the
players that the packers have given them
in that draft it may be jordan loves
draft to use those players to try to go
to a super bowl go win a super bowl so
he may leave leave there with one super
bowl and it all started with the
drafting of jordan love and it just
seemingly mike has gone downhill from
there
rob demosky of espn has reported that
the packers think the 49ers and the
broncos have tampered with aaron rodgers
and i would suspect i don't think
demovsky explained it this way my guess
would be it was solicited tampering by
rogers camp trying to generate a trade
market getting the word out that there's
reason to call remember last week when
the 49ers made that call wednesday night
kyle shanahan told rich eisen earlier
this week he didn't want to wake up
friday morning and find out that aaron
rodgers had been traded to someone else
he had reason to believe that there was
reason to call
and
i think that there were communications
and they can't be proven the packers
aren't going to claim tampering they're
not going to have a smoking gun
gms front office detective coaches they
aren't stupid about this and even when
they are the nfl arbitrarily and
selectively enforces the tampering rules
but i suspect that rogers people have
been making phone calls trying to get
certain teams to contact
the packers and if you do anything other
than hang up the phone immediately and
report that communication to the packers
you violated the tampering rules
well you go back to 2008 mike and the
packers accused the vikings of the exact
same thing with brett favre and nothing
led to it so it is selective when the
nfl chooses to enforce these you pointed
out that jeremy macklin won
with the chiefs talking to macklin when
he was still under contract with the
eagles i think that's probably the last
time that any team
suffered consequences from tampering
with player we know it goes on all the
time and it probably did happen in this
case no question now whether it was
rogers camp calling these teams are
these teams calling rogers camp however
that worked out i'm sure there was
probably some communication otherwise
how would the 49ers know to pick up the
phone and call on wednesday night and
say hey just in case you're considering
trading aaron rodgers dot dot dot so i
do believe there was some conversation
there mike
and you know even though the packers may
not be able to prove that there was a
smoking gun that there was some sort of
communication there's been enough said
publicly by gm john lynch and by
shanahan i mentioned the comment that he
made to rich eisen the other day that
would at least make it plausible if the
packers wanted to
make tampering charges and have an
investigation launched and that's why
it's always smart to say
we don't talk about players who are
under contract with other teams period
then you avoid that problem altogether
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports